who would be my LeBron of the NFL  Aaron Rodgers he's like the poster child  for success and championships and he's  even though he's only won one like you  like identify Aaron Rodgers with like  winning and success and that would be my  LeBron James my stuff of the NFL would  have to be Cooper cup nice clean shaving  wins championships it's the best at his  position been the best for a very long  time doesn't have like a super flashy  game but it's super effective and he  racks up all type of records and all  type of points that would be me  I love winning I've just created this  obsession with winning I'm not afraid to  go to another team and do it I've been  on super teams been playing football for  a long time and all I want to do is win  and I want to put myself in the best  winning situation that I possibly can  you got a burner account I do yeah I do  I mean I can't give it to you because  it's not a burner account anymore but  yeah I got I got a little Finster  [Music]